just reading
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's happening there reject nation we
are back to watch a new rockstars video
and this is something i i didn't know
anything about that there was apparently
you could look at some pages of the
screenplay i didn't have spiderman no
way home so of course the boys went to
work spider-man no way home hidden
details in the screenplay itself i'm
very much excited to check this out
actually if you watch our spider-man
premiere video that we did when we were
able to attend it thank you again koi
zhandra gotta interview the
screenwriters for a brief moment in time
they'll remember be forever i am not
just part of many people who got to
speak with them anywho let's get to it
subscribe to new rock stars if you
haven't done so already welcome back to
new rockstars i'm eric boss and
spider-man no way home was embedded with
even more secret layers of meaning than
we realized because this film's official
screenplay was just released and let me
tell you while it wasn't staring
wide-eyed and screaming and crying at
this movie in imax it was one hell of a
read that still made me do all of those
things i can't believe we can read this
all 181 pages of this to find a ton of
new details that are not that obvious
from watching this film some deeper
context subtext literal texts that made
me appreciate this movie's attention to
detail even more and the fact that this
movie snuck in a stan lee cameo i swear
to god if they weaken it stan leave this
let's break this down now the version of
the no way home screenplay that has been
released is the final script the draft
submitted for awards consideration film
scripts are gonna show
that evolve throughout production and
post-production to give each department
a blueprint or the movie as it comes
together so this draft is likely one
that the screenwriters assembled after
the film's release to best reflect what
we actually saw in the film the title
page reads serenity now the no way home
production title before its public title
was decided and announced serenity now
is a reference to the sitcom seinfeld
season 9 episode 3 in which george's
father frank costanza repeats the phrase
serenity now really is a calming mantra
that he heard from a self-help tape but
because this is frankistanza it just
makes him angrier and bottles up his
rage
now when we first heard the production
title this movie was going to be
serenity now it just seemed like a
random seinfeld joke really many
production titles are just random
phrases however if you think about it
the core emotional arc for peter parker
in no way home is to embrace aunt may's
zen mindset of helping people instead of
dooming them and despite peter's rage
exploding against green goblin he must
channel his inner serenity now and let
it go he should have shouted serenity
now wow you can live goblet yeah
now the monster worked instead of like
peter with great power who's great
responsibility she sure just looked at
him and said peter
serenity now just grabbed him by the
face and then toby and andrew be like
serenity now what the hell is this
in this dimension the opening pages
transcribe exactly what we saw and
noticed in the film until page five the
exposition says that flash's phone
screen shows the daily bugle official
tick tock now you may have caught this
in the quick cut two in the movie but it
is fun to see the script tie in with
that whole thing of that betty brandt
being the daily bugle
now another fun visual detail that's
hard to catch while watching the movie
when the brick flies into the window
caught by charlie cox matt murdock
daredevil the script confirms that the
newspaper message wrapped around the
brick misspells the word of believe
almost like they didn't want to spell
this pro-material message with the word
lie in it now jumping ahead with the
bridge battle against that's clever
that's clever the direction reads
spider-man versus doc mono amano amano
etc because you know like 16 different
appendages are fighting here and then a
bit further down it directs doc ock's
tentacles to grab spider-man's arms in a
vice as another tentacle latches onto
the daily bugle helicopter the fact that
dock uses the helicopter rotors to try
to kill peter is obvious enough but i
only now put it together that dog was
using the daily bugle helicopter oh wow
to try to kill him in this moment wow
that's so funny you know that's probably
the first time i've ever heard of an
instance i'm sure it's like it happened
before but that's the first time i've
ever heard of an instance where the
scripps action lines help you better see
what's happening in the actual action
scene cause a lot of the time with
action scenes they're just chalked up to
previz or the descriptions are so brief
in there because they figure it out with
the actual filmmakers on set to see that
like oh actually if you if you read the
action line then you pay attention to
the movie they're doing that description
well that's what makes me want to see
like earlier drafts too to see where
those things made their way in as
specific details we need to include you
know true then jumping ahead to page 76
when peter finds may having tea with
norman osborne the description reads no
armor dressed in ill-fitting clothes
from the donation bin nursing tea in a
mug he looks tired disoriented even
fragile so when we watch the movie it
isn't confirmed where exactly norman got
these green and purple sweats but now we
know it was from the donation bin which
means that norman walked into this feast
center still wearing his goblin armor so
someone at feast maybe even may saw him
enter the doors as a multiversal
supervillain and still decided to give
this guy a second chance then shortly
after this on pam
another subtext detail that i
appreciated when norman meets mj in the
sanctum at first he thinks mj is for
mary jane as we know from the film she
corrects him but then the script says
norman reacts understanding another
universe which leads him to say
fascinating so i love this just from mj
standing for different names in this
reality the brilliant norman osborne
already deduces the multiverse logic of
that and how the magic keeps some
aspects of the identity the same but
warps them slightly yeah it's funny
because a lot of the times you hear with
screenwriting that you don't want to do
too much of internal monologuing within
the description itself like sometimes
directors don't like having that
sometimes they are okay with that you
kind of want to keep it to a minimum or
to the point where you're not being too
novelistic about it especially if you're
the writer and not the director of it as
well no room for interpretation that
makes perfect sense to me because in the
movie itself like what he says
fascinating i think most of us would
conclude that oh he's putting it
together multiverse he knows what's
happening that is a great thing to point
to as internal monologue of what's
probably happening with norman osborn
and how through the direction the
performance of willem dafoe we're able
to know what he's talking about when he
says fascinating really the bigger
detail is a few pages after this doctor
strange's box now hearing the name of it
i thought it was the machina dicotomis
but in the script it is spelled la
machina d cadavers which is italian for
the machine of cadavers italian being a
key language because it's a nationality
of cagliostro the sorcerer who wrote
commerce's book of caglio stroke but the
word cadavers is an important easter egg
because it refers to the crystal of
cadavers which comes from the marvel
team up number 21 in 1977.
who hypnotizes peter into stealing the
crystal cadavers which zandu needs in a
plot to resurrect his wife the word
cadavers a play on cadaver what's
amazing about this is months ago i
actually found a clue in the trailer of
a car on the bridge with a license tag
of
mtu-2174 which was a reference to this
exact comic my man plate was removed
from the final cut of the film and on
the next page page 84 it says that when
strange activates a box golden light was
supposed to begin enveloping the
villains in their cells but
interestingly they left this out of the
film and saved it for when the spell was
complete at the end now in peter's
confrontation with strange in the mirror
dimension on page 88 peter using
geometry to best strange is described in
a pretty fun way strange looks around
webs everywhere closing in on him as the
rocks turn and spin not so random after
all as strange is completely ensnared in
a web i love describing it this way
because it reflects the way strange used
to see the universe as random tiny
momentary specs within an indifferent
universe but the lesson strange must
learn is that there is always a deeper
order to the chaos than he thinks so
jumping yes yes
damn damn totally did not catch this
under the music and the tears of this
moment but among peter's last words to
me are it's just me and you okay it's
just me and you calling back may
connecting with him in homecoming you
have to tell me what's going on just lay
it out it's just me and you which in
that moment wow her way of saying it's
just down to the two of us since ben
died we have to trust each other and now
peter is echoing that here and she will
always be that important mother figure
to him that's a great great call to pick
up on man because in terms of book
ending the story of aunt may in your
trilogy you know when you want to mirror
that effect in terms of character arc he
says that to him and then now it's the
reversal where he's saying that to her
that is really cool writing and that's
something that like a true fans of eric
voss himself the fact that he was able
to pick up on that is uh incredible yeah
that
nope
and that's those kind of like
character-driven easter eggs that really
show like the true intent behind this
movie because there are so many of those
that hearken back not just to like oh
neat reference but to yeah like really
important character beats what they
should have done is done a flashback
when ant-may says it really just do it
so overtly so expositional-wise
it'd be like audience you're too tough
here you go angles repeating the present
yeah yeah now one of my most favorite
things about reading the script is also
my favorite part of the film the
introduction of andrew garfield peter
and toby maguire peter and in this
script started on page 119 to avoid
confusion among the peters these two are
labeled as web verse peter and rainy
versus peter
i want to copy
copy
[Music]
[Laughter]
those script copies i mean they said
this is like to match the final draft of
the movie or whatever but you got to
imagine that appeared in earlier ones
and they must have kept those scripts so
tightly locked down like can you imagine
one page leaked because it says web
verse i was like okay that's kind of
confusing it's confusing yeah but that
was like oh it's two beasts for mark
webb yeah
yeah yeah and then a few pages later on
page 127 when mj and ned bring the other
peters to the midtown roof they're
initially silhouetted in the light of
the moon and peter doesn't recognize
them at first so the script says peter
takes a protective stance guarding his
friends meaning that peter did not know
what other multiversal villains could
have arrived threatening his loved ones
so his instinct is to protect his only
loved ones left for getting killed that
shows in the movie that these two are on
his side and this is pretty clear in the
scene i just love reading this in the
script on page 129 as all three peters
finish each other's with great power
lines the exposition says they're
overwhelmed by this uncanny connection
bound together across universes by those
words just further underlining that
quote as a kind of absolute point that
defines all peter parker's regardless of
their dimensions fun little detail on
page one thirty three when scripture
knows how to use nuances confusingly
pointed each other the script straight
up says memes showing the things
of the spiderman pointing at each other
meme and then during the final battle
when andrew garfield peter chats with
max dillon about the existence of a
black spider-man on page 159 it says
webb vs peter nods there probably is now
the way they formulated this is
interesting because it's described as
andrew garfield peter's thought but also
it's still formatted in a way to leave
open for interpretation that miles
morales spider-man does indeed exist in
this live-action multiverse i wonder if
that's an indicator that by the point in
time of andrew garfield's universe the
way that reads where it's italicized
that's usually a signal for like an
internal thought that this character
might be having so maybe he was just
thinking yeah there probably is a black
spider-man out there or if it's an
indicator that by this point in time the
amazing spider-man the universe that the
miles morales exists in his already that
seems plausible a good amount of time
has passed to where peter would be older
and miles could probably be coming up as
a fledgling spider-man but granted you
know if when we do get live-action miles
i think it would be cool to pluck him
straight out of the spider burst the
animated and watch him be a live-action
format that'd be neater then on to the
final moments in this donut shop one of
the weirdest things i found in the
script on page 177 peter finds mj
talking and laughing with an older
customer uh see i i i thought that
i didn't wonder why the camera lingered
on this guy in mj's moment with him i
wondered if he could be some vip or
comics writer but he is an actor named
edward force and now the script is
suggesting that this guy was cast for
his resemblance to stan lee did the
script intend for us to see this
resemblance are we meant to see him as a
stanley variant or really is it just to
evoke the memory of stan's mini cameo i
think it's that kind of vague deja vu
and facial blindness is that him no not
quite cause that's what that did to me
feeling in this scene either way i think
it's just a cool weird thing to keep in
the script and this scene hints at mj's
inner thoughts while chatting with peter
when he finishes her line about
expecting disappointment because then
you'll never actually be disappointed it
says a flicker of deja vu on her face
and then on the next page as peter
decides not to tell her and walks out
the door it says hold on mj watching
peter go with the lingering sense of
recognition and then we move on to the
final sequence as peter swings in with
his new suit on page 181 the script
describes it as a blue and red suit new
for him but reminiscent of the suits
he's seen before
that peter was directly inspired by
those hand-stitched brighter colors of
the suits of his predecessors
rather than having a billionaire
engineer to sign all your tech for you
an important rite of passage is to
stitch your own suit and then the
awesome final words of the script he
swings with a newfound sense of freedom
liberated from having to juggle two
lives peter parker is no more but
spider-man lives on fade out beautiful
ah yes now while it is easy to walk out
of this film feeling a bit down about
the stranger peter now is in his world
cut off from everyone he loves hearing
it this way reminds me of how his peter
parker identity always weighed him down
the opening shot to spider-man
homecoming showed us a kid itching to
escape from his life as a bullied high
school student so that he could come
alive finally at the end of the day as a
masked friendly neighborhood spider-man
it's better sweet this ending finally
gives him that freedom you can support
rockstars by checking out our merch
options rockstarsmerch.com i want to
read that
twitter
avos follow me rockstars subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
damn that's cool that's cool i didn't
know i did not know it was online sounds
like it's official i don't feel like any
rock stars would cover it entirely
they stole it themselves to get the
scoop yeah that was amazing yeah i
really i really enjoyed that a lot
that's one of my that's got to be one of
my favorites i've seen of new rock stars
to be totally honest great look into the
process someone who that has a passion
for writing i i do i did really really
appreciate that one a lot all right guys
well subscribe to nr if you haven't done
so already you can subscribe to us and
uh thanks for being here leave a like if
you can catch you guys soon